SPEAKER: Today's big
data applications
tend to have a very
common data problem.
While they all
have the tools they
need to manage volumes
of information,
they still lack the
ability to generate insight
from that data.
And with traditional databases,
this is pretty tricky.
Legacy relational database
management systems
are great at managing
lists of items,
but cumbersome for defining
how they relate to each other.
Eventually, they realize
that the relationships
between data points matter
more than the individual points
themselves.
This is where Neo4j comes in.
It's a graph database,
meaning that relationships
between items are a
first class citizen,
allowing it to help you
generate valuable insights
about your data while
also remaining flexible
when expanding a data model or
conforming to changing business
needs.
Graph is a core technology
that powers hundreds
of different use cases, from
real time recommendations
to fraud detection to network
and IT operations, master data
management, and more.
On the technical
side, Neo4j fits along
with any microservices
you may develop,
can be used with Neo4j's
Bloom visualization,
or as a store for graph
QL-based applications,
analytics services, or any other
app deployed in a Kubernetes
easily.
And here at Neo4j,
we love Kubernetes.
We provide Docker containers,
allowing customers
to run in a clustered setup
for query scalability.
But we found that customers
quickly ran into problems when
the containers proliferate.
Thankfully, Kubernetes solves
the orchestration problem
with less work for you.
Kubernetes has many advantages
for improving operations,
but it can be challenging
for new users to set up.
This is why Neo4j leverage
is Google Kubernetes Engine.
GKE is the best form of
managed Kubernetes that
allows our customers to
focus on the business
applications of their graph and
not be concerned with cluster
provisioning and maintenance.
And with GCP marketplace,
you can go from zero
to a working clustered
graph database
in less than five minutes.
Simply choose the Neo4j
solution, fill in some data,
and get moving.
It's a fast and easy way
for you to get started.
GCP marketplace is
great, because it
gets you kickstarted with a
working setup tailored to best
practices quickly, while
still allowing power users
access to the
underlying resources,
so you can always customize
to your deployment needs.
And it also lets users
track Neo4j deployments
as a single unified app in
our Kubernetes cluster instead
of just a bunch of
interrelated containers
Google Kubernetes Engine
combined with GCP marketplace
provide best in class
services for our Neo4j users
it lets you get up
and running fast
so you can focus on
your data and extracting
the value from that,
rather than all
of the work of setting up
and managing your database
clusters.
If you'd like to
know more, check out
the links in the
description below and feel
free to reach out with
any questions or comments
you may have.
Thanks for watching.